there's a wonderful seeing the citizen
where Ibrahim is interviewing for a job
any interviews with the man who appears
he's not American born and he has a very
Americanized name it makes me think of
someone like Danny Thomas and I'm sure
there's others who feel a pressure maybe
or just of their own personal desire to
change their name do you think that
that's something that's pushed on people
of other as ethnicities or it's just a
personal choice you think that's a real
well I mean I i feel it's it's a
combination and it's up to you to make a
decision and it does not mean that this
is right or wrong it's your own decision
as it was for a brain everyone he made a
decision he's unique he's he's different
and he felt that was imposed on him and
he made a decision not to do it if this
is the case it doesn't mean that he
might not change his name later during
his life to make it easier on people to
pronounce or two you know it's like my
original name is samer and everybody
calls me Sam it's easier to communicate
sometimes it's easier to market you know
and then a lot of factors into it but
not to be imposed on you not to like for
somebody it's not right to be forced to
change your name just to get a job now
if this is the case and you and you said
yes it's it's up to you this is your
personal decision but I don't think I
don't think it's it's right and
sometimes yet yes it is a pressure and
sometimes it's a it's no pressure is
just pleasure is just to help you know I
kind of like a name that you feel it it
will connect and with people and it's
easier but I think it's a personal
choice then
you